وزاره الدفاع الروسيه صورا قالت انها
لهجوم صاروقي استهدف مواقع للقوات
الاوكرانيه باتجاه الامام واضافت ان
القوات الجويه والمدفعيه صدتها هجمات
للقوات الاوكرانيه على منطقه اوريجينيا
واشرت الوزاره الى ان قواتها دمرت مقرا
تابعا للقوات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
ماكاروفكا ومركز مراقبه اضافه الى تدمير
محطه رادار ونظاما صاروخي مضادا للدبابات
في منطقه نوفو ميخاي لوفكا
المتحدث باسم قوات الغرب في الجيش الروسي
ان القوات الروسيه صدتها هجمات اوكرانيه
على مواقع للجيش الروسي باتجاه كوبيانسك
واكد ان القوات الروسيه سيطرت على مواقع
للقوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه اولشانا
من اجل استعاده المواقع المفقوده في اتجاه
كوبيانس نفذ العدو خلال النهار 6 هجمات
مضاده على مواقعنا وتصدينا لجميع الهجمات
وقد سيطرت المجموعات الهجوميه لقواتنا على
ثلاثه معاقل وثلاثه مراكز مراقبه وهزمت
وحده مشاه بالقرب من قريه اولشانا نفذ
الطيران الحربي 8 غارات على تجمعات لوحدات
اوكرانيا في منطقه
السلطات المواليه لروسيا مقتل شخصين
واصابه خمسه في هجوم اوكرانيا على مناطق
مختلفه واضافت ان القوات الاوكرانيه نفذت
74 هجوما باكثر من 250 قذيفه صاروخيه
واوضحت ان 45 قذيفه كانت تحمل رؤوسا حربيه
عنقوديه واشارت السلطات الى ان الهجوم
اسفر عن تدمير مبال عده في المقاطعه